sean put something on here that i
actually think i was telling uh a friend
as i was researching i actually think
that this is one of the better ideas
that we and you you've ever come up with
the michael jordan thing all right
yeah you want me to explain it okay so
um
i've been looking at this house for a
long time michael jordan's house has
been for sale for like a decade and it
hasn't sold and this is his house uh
kind of like you know in illinois near
chicago where you know michael jordan
was on the bulls and he had this 56 000
square foot home in highland park
and
so this thing originally he put it up
for sale and like i don't know nine
years ago for 30 million 29 million
dollars and
now it's you know the price has been cut
in half and the thing is still not
selling and if you look at the photos
you can just go it's like on zillow so
you can go look at the photos he's got
like an indoor basketball court you know
the gate leading up to the driveway has
his big 23 number like embossed in it
he's got you know everything you would
want like huge you know closets because
he's got you know all his air jordans or
whatever and so his house is
it's pretty unbelievable right there's
there's all kinds of um
epic [__] here but it's not selling and
it's not selling for i think a couple
reasons it's like you know it's very
custom to michael jordan um like it just
it's like it was custom made in many
senses so you know that other rich
people don't necessarily want to live in
a house that's like made for another
dude um it's also you know it's very
expensive for the area the property
taxes are really expensive all that
stuff but i was thinking okay the price
is now cut in half now it's now it's a
13 million dollar house or a 12 you know
13 million home that you could buy
13 14 and
now it's in range where maybe there's
something fun you could do with it now
you might be getting a value buy so i
was thinking
all right there's a bunch of people
obviously that are basketball fans that
love michael jordan um there's a bunch
of you know new ways to crowdfund that
we've been talking about nfts or uh
kickstarter or different different
crowdfunding platforms so
the question is
should we buy michael jordan's house
should we start a crowdfunding campaign
and buy michael jordan's house so if you
could get
5 000 people to each put in 2 500
then you can own a fractional share of
michael jordan's house uh you could you
you could own a piece of of this history
and we could just buy it out take it off
the market
um and we could own this thing and then
the question is like what do you do with
it um and so i wanted to brainstorm with
you a should we buy michael jordan's
house and b what could we do with it if
we did buy it what do you think
so the whole nft thing i wouldn't do
that i think that i think you've had two
ideas here one is to buy his house and
two is to end do the nft thing uh one of
those ideas is great i think the other
one is over complicating it i would 100
buy it and the reason why i think it's
such a great idea is immediately after
you seeing you write this my
thought right away went to graceland you
know what graceland is no
that's funny that you don't know what
that is it's because it's such a big
deal in my family or elvis is at least
so graceland is elvis presley's house uh
it's in memphis it's in downtown memphis
it's actually in a pretty crappy
neighborhood now or the neighborhood is
not nice and it's like kind of gross but
it's just like a cutesy thing to do if
you visit memphis and i went and did
research on it and so around 600 000
people a year go to graceland which
brings in something like where i have
the numbers here okay so graceland just
in attendance uh just in ticket sales
brings in 21 million dollars
so it's yeah pretty wild just on tickets
600 000 visitors a year
uh 36 a ticket right
yes
and i got interested in this so i
thought what are the most visited homes
in america so i came up with a few and i
want to fill you in on them so the white
house doesn't count because you can just
you i think you can get a tour but you
could also just walk outside of it but
graceland six hundred thousand the
second one i'm you guys are gonna make
fun of me i don't know how to pronounce
this what is it monticello i think so
okay monticello that's uh thomas
jefferson's house and so the interesting
thing about this place as well as a few
other i'm going to mention is that
they're non-profits which means all of
their numbers are public and so uh the
revenue for monticello which includes a
ton of investment revenue was around 200
million dollars
in 2010 but around uh 8 million 7
million came just from ticket sales so 8
million a year in ticket sales which is
crazy and they have around 500 000
people another uh most visited home is
never uh like homes that people drive by
neverland ranch people don't go there
but the other another great one is mount
vernon which is uh i think
uh
what's our first president george
washington's house uh
and they do
in in in uh food sales alone this is
crazy just in food seventeen million
dollars a year
wow is that crazy it's a whole insane
the whole operations
and then they do 15 million dollars a
year in admission sales and in total
they do about 51 million dollars a year
in total income which includes 10
million from contributions
is that crazy that no that's absolutely
insane so let me ask you these okay so
this all of a sudden this starts to get
really interesting right because i think
michael jordan is on par with elvis and
you know thomas jefferson michael
jordan's got tj beat by a long shot so
you know mj over tj i think is is part
of the the slogan that we have when we
when we buy this thing but um if they're
doing this much in traffic i got to know
is there something else meaning like are
these in really hot like popular areas
uh where there's already just a lot of
tourists or something like that and this
is just a pit stop because you know
michael jordan's house is in a
neighborhood you'd have to only be going
to go to this place
i looked up michael jordan's address
guess how far away it is from chicago
airport one of the most popular airports
in the world i'm gonna guess 45 minutes
20 minutes
it's 20 minutes away okay so it's at
like have you been in memphis memphis is
like there's not that much going on in
memphis and all these people are going
to memphis um
people are chicago's what the fifth most
populous city in america or maybe third
something like that
something is interesting here so what i
would do is i wouldn't do the nft thing
i would raise
uh two or three million dollars from a
bunch of rich people
um or i would try to use my own money if
i had two or three million dollars that
i wanted to spend on this
and i would buy it and then it would
probably cost a fair bit of money to
get it set up it would probably cost a
lot of money another many more millions
but then you'd have to convince
collectors
to
lend you the stuff and you create a
michael jordan museum yes
and
that's how you do this and the companies
that we've just mentioned
graceland monticello and um
mount vernon so those obviously those
folks lived in the 1700s or probably
died in the 1800s so they've been around
those properties have been around as
tourist destinations for a hundred plus
years
but
they've done 50 million revenue which is
a [__] ton but even if you've just um
two or three million dollars in revenue
and you could do that and adjust for
inflation for 50 plus years kind of like
graceland has done it for 60 years
that's incredibly fascinating right
yeah i'm with you so so i think you you
know you're [__] on the nft thing a
little bit but it's not about nft what
i'm saying is crowdfunding um so i think
that there's a benefit to crowdfunding
which is that crowdfunding is a way to
make the story more viral um it is a
it's a more pr worthy story that
uh you know people from the internet
people from reddit whoever got together
and bought michael jordan's home off the
market for for 15 million dollars they
raised 15 million dollars and bought the
house versus a rich guy went to his rich
friends and raised some money the second
thing is those become you know
your evangelist to spread the word and
to come make the uh the pilgrimage to go
see michael jordan's house and i think
you could do two or three things with it
i think you could make it a museum
that's like a modern museum that we've
been talking about like the museum of
ice cream
or something like that where the tour is
very heavy um photo based and so you're
you know you're going through
and it's all these different photo
exhibits of you know
you in michael jordan's bed and you know
wearing you know a pair of his air
jordans or standing in a pair of giant
air jordans or something like that and
you make it like a museum of ice cream
where you're going to walk out with you
know 10 photos that are instagram worthy
at the end of it i also think
give give people
background on an ice cream museum yeah
you can pull the latest numbers but i
think these guys uh raised it like a 100
million dollar plus valuation and if you
if you ever go to one they're pretty
cool it's you know it's not the most
amazing thing i honestly i was a little
bit disappointed but the photos do turn
out cool it's a museum that you walk
through uh so it's like a guided path
and you go through maybe like 13
different rooms and every room is
something cool and you get a little you
know you get an ice cream cone of some
flavor and then you can take photos next
to some like exhibit that they've set up
and the idea is not for you to look at
the art like a traditional museum but
for you to like take a photo in the art
uh and post it on instagram and that's
their marketing that's the free
marketing that they get and so museum of
ice cream oh yeah here everybody has it
they raised 40 million they raised a 40
million dollar series a at a 200 million
dollar valuation last year and um and i
think this could be bigger
i think this could be much much bigger
as a brand um the other thing
the other thing that you could do is uh
sports cards are having this incredible
boom right now and i think what you
could do is you could have certain
collectors put their collection um
in in the house the house could be
basically the vault to store some of the
most rare memorabilia in the sports
world sign basketball shoes and sports
cards and that could be part of the
museum and you you basically store it
and you
you store it for some of these
collectors so i think i think there's a
bunch of stuff you could do to make this
work but the idea is like can you buy
this thing for 13 million put another
four or five million into um you know
getting it all set up and then could you
make five million dollars a year could
you make 10 million dollars a year like
you're saying these other guys do um
as a pilgrimage for you know tourists
going to chicago and basketball junkies
i think the answer is definitely yes and
i think it's so interesting um i found a
i found another example of one and it's
called the um
it's called the national trust for
historic preservation and it's a
non-profit and all they do is buy
um
historical buildings and their historic
i looked at their numbers they've been
doing like 50 or 60 million in revenue
for years
and i'm still trying to figure out how
to entirely read uh nonprofit statements
but they have a buy a line item that's
revenue less expenses which
i guess that just means prop i mean i
don't know how they define yeah
i don't know how they define either of
those but it was 26 million
and it's been doing that for years
is that nuts so i like this idea i like
this idea a lot and i kind of want to
dig a little further into how these
um
homes home museums work because i think
this is pretty interesting the other
good thing about this by the way is that
the basketball hall of fame
sucks nobody cares about it nobody goes
to visit it
all the other sports like you know
canton for football these are like
tourist destinations you know tons of
people go there every year it's really
cool and the basketball one
is known to be super lame because they
let way too many people in and um and
it's not like it's not a thing that
basketball fans really care to go do
can i give you two more examples that we
what we could consider doing instead of
even doing a museum maybe this is even
simpler yeah so i'm staying at my friend
jack's house it's a badass house
um
five doors down or ten doors down
something like that
nearby
is what's they call it the obama house
and when obama was in office from uh
when was he in office oh the oh
the second the second term
um
or whatever it was he would stay at this
house down here and the owners let them
stay i think for a massive discount now
it's like it has its own wikipedia page
and it's called like the obama house and
it sold
10 years ago for 7 million after he had
already stayed there which sorry 7
million i said i say seven for seven
million which is a lot of money but they
rent it out right now on airbnb for six
thousand dollars a night
or if it's booked all the way up 180k a
month
and it's branded as the obama house
i think that you could absolutely crush
it with a jordan
airbnb house
would you and a group of friends be
willing to pull together three thousand
dollars a day to stay there maybe i
think the way you'd have to do it is
you'd have to make it like a vegas
alternative for bachelor parties and
stuff like that birthdays it's like what
is the man cave man dream vacation it's
like dude we're going to go stay in
michael jordan's house
14 of us are going um and it comes with
like all the amenities and you know all
that stuff this is where you go this is
where you want to go if you want to live
like the sports fans dream i think you
could do that i do like the museum one
better what was the second idea you had
you said you had
two oh what wasn't the second i guess it
was more so uh
just another example the fresh prince of
bel air house
um
it's it's kind of interesting but do you
remember living in san francisco how
there's like the what's it called the
painted ladies which is the whole the
full house house and then there's the
missed out firehouse
um i would just want to buy all these
and turn them all into twitter so i
lived a block away from the uh from the
full house house and uh literally 24 7
there is somebody standing outside of
that house during the daytime uh taking
a photo of it so there's just a constant
and it's not like it's not like a huge
line of people but there's always like
four people standing outside taking a
photo in front of the full house house
every single day for the whole year it's
kind of crazy and then it just sold
actually and it sold at basically like i
think 1.5 or 2x the market rate in that
area so um they got basically like a
double premium because it is the full
househouse which i think is you know
kind of interesting um but okay i think
we should uh i think we should buy
michael jordan's house i think we should
crowdfund uh i think we should crowdfund
five thousand people together we should
own this thing or we could go to rally
road and we could say hey rally let's
put michael jordan's house on rally and
uh
you know let's sell this baby out i
think if five thousand right now with if
you go on rally roads you'll get two
thousand or three thousand people buying
a fractional share of you know a pair of
jordans or a signed autograph or a
signed rookie card or something like
that [__] all that let's own the guy's
house so i think you could easily get
5000 people on rally road to buy a
fractional share of michael jordan's
house i'm surprised they don't already
do this if they're listening to this uh
you know go go for it just give us
credit and give me a share of the house
i actually think that they wouldn't do
that because how do you liquidate that
it's been on the market for 20 or how
long 10 years
no one is obviously no one's buying it
so like how do you get liquidity from
that after seven years i don't think you
don't i think the game here
right the point of rally is that they
take things that are not assets and they
make them not liquid assets they make
them liquid assets so because you can
own a fractional share now there's
liquidity any one person who owns a
piece of michael jordan's house can swap
it for anybody else who wants to own a
piece of it so you don't need a 15
million dollar buyer because you can
sell them in blocks of a thousand or
fifteen hundred dollars and so when you
bring that price point down there's
people who
want to own a piece of the a piece of
the art a piece of the asset which is
how they do like you know they'll sell
um you know a harry potter first edition
signed you know set of books
and uh you know instead of selling it
for 25 000
they'll get you know
2 000 investors to each put in whatever
whatever the math comes out to 150 bucks
to go buy
uh you know to own a piece of that thing
so they introduce liquidity by making it
fractionally owned
yes but there's still no cash flow you
have to create an operation around this
cash flow and there's no cash flow in a
basketball card there's no cash flow and
air jordans there's no cash flow and
harry potter first
asian investor willing to buy it
no dude
you're still thinking like the old world
you haven't seen what's going on in
raleigh you're staying with jack smith
you should go ask jack smith about how
this stuff works uh he's the one who who
taught me and he's one of the biggest
investors in this stuff he's not buying
it for cash flow um you know he's buying
it because
yeah there are there is another there is
another collector and when you make it
fractional now way more people can get
in on collecting it versus just the rich
deep pocketed people who could buy the
whole asset 100 percent
yeah bro but who
lik who liquidates it after a handful of
years on rally road
uh someone actually buys the car after a
few years very rarely occasionally
somebody comes and offers to buy out the
whole the whole lot um and then they put
it to a vote i don't know if you've seen
this but like you know let's say a box
of pokemon cards went on there uh like a
super rare pokemon card set they i don't
know what the ip what the ipo was but on
rally the ipod let's pretend it was 50
and then what happened is a is a big you
know asian investor came in and said
we'll buy this thing out for 85 000 now
so you'll all get a profit but we want
to own this thing and they put it to the
vote of all the share owners and they
said no they said we're going to hold it
we think it's going to go up so they
voted no they voted to keep it uh so
they're not all trying to liquidate um
soon you know some some people who are
buy and hold investors will want to own
these assets for a long time because
they think hey you know if i just hold
this now
you know what's michael jordan going to
be what's michael jordan's fame going to
be 20 years from now if michael jordan
passes away how much is it going to be
worth and there's people who are in it
for the long term so
i think there's i think the collectibles
thing is a little bit different than i
think about it differently than you do i
would say
you basically need jordan to have like a
tragic accident
or like for example dance came out so so
the last dance is ten part documentary
that came out on netflix and espn um
you know millions and millions of people
watch this thing and jordan's brand you
could see all the price of jordans went
up jordan's like brand visibility and
brand sentiment went up
because this documentary came out he's
still alive it wasn't a tragic event but
somebody told the jordan story to the
the younger generation who own you know
grew up where you know they were two
years old when jordan was at his prime
and so jordan brand got stronger with
the last dance coming out and i think
that's just going to continue you know
over time because he's got all these
different you know the legacy becomes
bigger than the person itself
[Music]
you